[Music]
there's a baby
and this baby's born with two dicks
like a snake that's crazy what a lucky
baby well you said like a snake snakes
have two dicks is that due to a
fertility drug or is it just naturally
occurring
i don't know dude it's just funny
it's just tight really like let's not
figure out how to prevent this just two
dicks mean four balls uh doesn't say
four balls just just two dicks i wonder
if it's double the feeling though do you
have a picture
jacking off like this they're just like
i don't think they were allowed to take
a picture of this baby's dick and does
it look like a double barrel shotgun or
like a slingshot or is it like one here
one there so it's a fork in the road
there's two full there's two two penises
two prongs they're of a different length
though that's true not joking so do they
get rid of one of them they had to get
rid of one of them which one did they
keep so what they had to get rid of the
larger penis why
why would you get rid of the larger one
maybe it's the less operable one oh like
maybe there's no pee pee hole oh it's
because the pee hole went through the
smaller one no they just it was um the
doctor's jealous they removed the second
penis he's like i want that dick
there can only be
that girl's sex toy that goes around on
instagram the rabbit yeah
with the little dick on the side oh the
baby was born with the rabbit the baby
was gonna be a professional woman
pleaser later on it's like this yep oh
jeez so unfortunately the baby could
only urinate from the smaller penis so
they had to remove the larger penis well
that makes sense it could future jizz
from the big one what happens if they
just left it what would have happened
they were afraid that it would make too
many uh women in their area of calm see
jealousy once once yeah that's what
happens when you have a jealous insult
doctor that's a hater ass doctor well
it's nerds it's also a difference right
like remember we did that article about
that chick who had two vaginas she was
in the adult industry and it's like one
of them was for her her man
the industry
i don't know let's see but like a chick
that has two vaginas they probably still
look regular in a sense whereas like if
a dude was walking around with like two
penises one not really functional one
was bigger than the other and it didn't
really work like there could be yeah you
know what i mean or what a good story
what a good party trick if you wear
sweatpants and you have a dick print on
both sides oh man the chicks are double
yeah
what happens when you get frisked by
cops though you'd always get freaks dude
the airport will not be fun for you yeah
remember that here you guys ever seen
that video of the cop frisking the guy
and he's grabbing his balls yeah his
dick that's my dick and he's like oh
[ __ ] what's that sorry my penis he knew
come on he doesn't know he's fighting
his lip the whole time nobody ever talks
about it
exactly you could tell on that 380p or
360p camera video i don't want a guy's
biting his lip i don't know what left
you know what a guy's biting his lips do
you think this baby would grow up to be
in a doublemint commercial
oh that would be good doublemint
commercial or [ __ ] twix the girl with
the two vaginas does she kill it on only
fans i'm sure she does right yeah like
do fetish stuff i think she was in the
just the porn industry in general i
don't know if i was oh well imagine if
this guy oh this baby grew up yeah
that's why it all depends on what his
personality ends up being like she's a
guy like you what if we
when we find out that every dude in a
doublemint commercial has two dicks
because we really wouldn't we really
don't have any reason
why like it's a prerequisite we have to
dig up the original casting call and see
if that was a note yeah make sure you
have the two dicks how do we know two
dicks a plus
that would just be his like his only
fan's name a i wonder how many people
have two dicks or born with two dicks
out of like whatever and then b i wonder
if there's ever been a triple dick
situation
oh man that's a great question the
siamese twin i wonder if there's a
triple dick situation you know what i
mean that's his fingers isn't it like
one eighth of a pan flute yeah yeah
that's a that's like yeah that's a bear
claw yeah yeah that's wolverine
it's wolverine in your pants so this is
a genetic irregularity called diphthalia
and it takes effect during the
development of the genital area it has
been posited that drugs infections or
other damage between the 23rd and 25th
day of gestation could lead to this
condition oh wow it's very specific yeah
so there's a way to do it on purpose
you say 23 today drugs on day 24.
the operation so the remaining skin
after the removal the remaining skin was
stitched together the operation seems to
have been a success
um the report says that he only has one
rather than two erection chambers and
the remaining penis so it's unclear
i forgot that it's chamber based
remember only you see the cross section
it looks like three chambers and it
fills with blood fills it
oh yeah so he doesn't have all of his
chambers at the moment i don't know how
it's gonna affect his sex you have 36
chambers can his name still be dick
richards
i don't think so not anymore do you
think that they give like the parents
the other dick just to keep the
souvenirs bronze it yeah yeah they do
that with umbilical cords right put it
in a jar yeah wouldn't you be like hey
you know what hey no no no give me my
son's extra dick like you ain't gonna
[ __ ] put that on what are you gonna
do with it do you think doctor he's
gonna throw his dick away this was timmy
d's kid do you guys think he would grow
and eat it what
is that what he said he did that with
the placenta
he did yeah
he made a video yeah he [ __ ] ate it
are you sure about that i know he did
well people do that regularly regular
yeah but why
they say it's better for uh what's the
depression called post-natal close yeah
cooking it though
for real that's what i've heard is that
the thing no that's that's what the
thought is there's a belief but
scientifically there's no proven effect
eat your own placenta yes
i mean they should they should keep it
for like [ __ ] stem cells right i used
to have a class with this guy in my
anatomy class and he said he just had a
baby no dude other guy who also had a
baby it's pretty common like i said
before
yeah placenta and he he made it into a
pill and him and his wife like took it
together that's better
but you know but why make him in all
kinds of things because they really
believe it it's just like you just
believe that it does something
what's the belief well according to
johns hopkins university they say that
eating the placenta is good for luck
there it is and they have some numbers
that you play a lot of left afterwards
so you go play craps right now yeah but
apparently this would you guys do it
there's so many different beliefs as to
what it does for you but like he said
one of them is for postnatal depression
like as a mother you're not going to
feel it i'm stuck on some titty milk but
i don't know if i'll [ __ ] eat
something it depends on what your doula
says that if every new year's you eat
black beans you have good luck and i
don't even do that so i probably won't
do this black bean beans specifically
why black beans or black eyed peas or
something just try it black guy can you
just try it for one year to see what
happens the bear of entries i got a
feeling
what does black eyed peas even look like
taboo
will i am fergie stupid wait you've
never seen blackberries sound like i got
a feeling
no the the actual p's damn it i want to
see what that looks like yeah yeah oh
you mean like back during the joints and
jams here
that's the joint
you know those are the actual pieces
when fergie came out i was like oh that
was kind of they're kind of like
conscious rap you know they're like a
cool little underground hip-hop crew and
then fergie came and they just went all
out mainstream and i'm like nobody had
somebody had a vision yeah i was like i
like them way better and they [ __ ]
made hella money
that's why we eat during thanksgiving is
it everything you dreamed it would be
gonna be a good no they're from around
here yeah really yeah uh apple the app
and will i am i think grew up in east
los and i think taboo went to roseman
high taboo's homie he's a homie yeah
that's so cool he's not on the show
montebello oh yeah
how come you don't bring him on the show
if he's a homie
because he would [ __ ] probably hate
this show what what do you mean it would
mess it would mess his vibe up yeah it's
not you know he doesn't want to talk
about eating whales he's probably gonna
be like where is the love
but we can sing along with it true you
know great song
well he would he would be willing to get
[ __ ] at least
let's get [ __ ]
let's get rid of no no here he would get
it started
the radio editor 2022 you know
time machine edit yes
i wonder if the jk fans are still like
big uh black ip fans do you think they
know the songs i don't i don't think so
why they're too old there's gotta
there's gotta be at least two or three
that are still alive i mean the young
ones probably don't know who black eyed
peas are who does tonight's gonna be a
good night who does that one ten yeah
that's black eyed peas yeah it's gonna
be a good night
so placenta i feel like they well i i
listened to them before that they're
like poppy poppy right but when they got
like really popular like poppy poppy
poppy that's that's our era though of
youtube and like how you know every one
of the dance crews and everything so
that was a good
time but i don't ever remember going
like [ __ ] man their songs just hit so
hard like i could find [ __ ] [ __ ] but
they were hitting so many in a row like
they were like hot they're going gold
topping dude but it was like in every
club yeah every everywhere every mall
every bathroom in the casino yeah they
were all stars so it is understood that
men with duplicate penises can still
have normal sex lives on children if
they join the black eyed peas yeah would
you not eat the placenta then like in
the future
i don't know if it was requested i'm not
as familiar with that uh idea or concept
so right now i'm like what but like if
it was like socially like if i
understand do you know what a placenta
looks like a bag all i know is that a
testicle bag imagine having two dicks
and then being like i have a normal sex
life
i don't know how to imagine that not a
[ __ ] flex isn't it that's kind of a
flex how would that logistically work
but it depends on how the two dicks look
like too if it's over under then one
goes in the hole the one just pounds the
clitoris or the [ __ ] with pounds of
clitoris so you could just be like mr dp
no pound it man oh you gotta pound it
hard [ __ ] hit it hard wouldn't that
be so cool if the two dick dude met the
two vagina girl and it was like a nice
like two pro that's like the avengers
isn't that but you know what it sucks if
her [ __ ] is like this and his dick is
like this then you just gotta put her
sideways so see he just gotta [ __ ]
like that that's fine that's easy wow
that's assuming they put plug in a plug
that'd be nice that's fate you think
there's like that's like the um it was a
total recall the the triple tip chick
you think that happens oh three titties
yeah the total recall one it does happen
right does it
maybe no i'm leaving my wife
[Laughter]
i saw a dog with eight titties eight
titties yeah don't they usually have six
i don't know how i'm looking up if can
you marry a dog
[Laughter]
oh wait wait wait some people say
they're already dead
what are we talking about
i got a feeling
[Music]
you